new terror strategy from Isis and
al-qaeda CBS News has learned that the
groups have made even more advances in
sneaking bombs inside laptop computers
and making them undetectable by security
concerns that those bombs could be
smuggled onto airliners cause the United
States to take action last month
passengers flying to the US direct from
eight muslim-majority countries were
banned from carrying on any electronic
devices larger than a cell phone via we
are now learning that terror groups are
using airport security technology to
test out their theories Kris Van Cleave
reports US intelligence officials tell
CBS News terror groups such as al-qaeda
and Isis are perfecting and testing a
bomb that could get past airport
scanners the new intelligence suggests
they have been testing the explosives on
airport scanners used to examine
carry-on luggage exactly one week ago a
ban went into place barring laptops
tablets and other large electronics from
carry-on luggage on flights to the US
and UK from airports in 10 different
cities in the Middle East and North
Africa US officials were concerned about
a repeat of this last February a bomb
concealed in a laptop detonated on board
a Somali airliner shortly after takeoff
the plane landed safely in a statement
to CBS News the Department of Homeland
Security says terrorist groups continue
to target commercial aviation to include
smuggling explosive devices in
electronics US officials have been
gathering information on the threat for
some time some supporting intelligence
was obtained in January in the US
military raid in Yemen that killed Navy
SEAL ryan owens for CBS this morning
saturday Kris Van Cleave Washington